[Music]
okay thank you sorry a bit random
alright okay so and we need to speak
today about something quite different
I'm I'm not a machine learning person
I'm a theoretical you know scientist I'm
interested in no coding and such and not
necessarily going to present you fancy
computations but I think at the
beginning of a theory for beginning of
an approach that could allow us to
understand the amazing capabilities of
the brain to learn and adapt to its
environment also to do that with
learning rules that appear to be very
limited in scope because contrary to
deep networks in general the brain has
only can only learn based on pre and
postsynaptic messages so things that
happen very locally in a seconds but
first I want to share with your Hugh
random images I don't know did on the
internet last night so here the only
point I wanted to make is that well the
reason I went into you neuroscience and
not in math physics is because
biological system are incredibly
beautiful to my opinion at least and
they are incredibly organized and they
are incredibly complicated but something
that will I will never be persuaded of
is that there could be something in them
that we will never understand or that
it's not there because it has to be
there for evolutionary your behavior
purposes despite that I mean simple
organizing organ of in organism sorry
like the C elegans we are just a few
hundred cells we still don't understand
exactly how this never system works and
if we go to our brain
seven complicated because we don't even
know the behavior we don't we gotta know
even properly describe the behavior that
the burden you have your problem and the
brain is supposed to solve but something
for sure is that it's not because our
brain is bigger that is less organized
or beautiful than the brain of C elegans
and it's it's incredibly packed in there
it's incredibly organized Celt the more
we characterize excitation the more we
characterize the circuits the more the
less random it looks right and on the
other hand we have to live with data
like this it's absolutely fabulous right
anybody that because data in the brain
knows how viable this response is so
here you have the response of a single
cell to a very simple stimulus emotion
stimulus and on the tribe a trial basis
you find that the spikes counts the
spike times everything varies to the
extent that from a single cell it's very
hard to know when the stimulus started
and if you if you give me thousands of
spiking neurons recorded at the same
time like well we have now what the hell
do I do with that right because not only
is it known very valuable but there's
also a lot of correlations structure in
that activity that I don't know how to
characterize or relate to behavior
excetera and i don't think that because
of this of this apparent so this would
be this would appear like a particularly
inefficient way of computing or quitting
information right because it looks so
noisy it would suggest that information
that each nerve interesting or neuron is
extremely unreliable that in order to
understand things we should look at very
large population of cells on average
after we see about large population of
cells and a very wide portion of
computational neuroscience i've dealt
with this approach with all population
coding etc or whether it seems to
contrast with everything else we know
about neural circuits at least in my
opinion so maybe we should step back a
little and try to understand its
variability and not as hindrance on
either how the brain computes or how we
can build networks that computes but has
a true feature that is a signature of
the brain amazing
capabilities so I spoke to you about
local learning and that's something I
want to insist on here because it's it's
you could see that as a hard constraints
as a hindrance right if you want to
train networks in the brain you need to
train their sinuses and the synapse is
weight can only be change roughly based
on pre and post synaptic biophysical
messages so you don't have access to the
global error made by the system you
don't have access to direct access so
the reward the input the output you're
very very far synaptically from the
motor system or the sensory order the
retina so based on this local messages
it would be very hard to learn any
global function so the way artificial
neural networks so that is they use
algorithms such as back propagation
which are not local but but sort of back
propagate through the circuit the error
that are measured behaviorally
unfortunately the brain cannot do that
should we consider that as a hindrance
I'm not so sure right I think it's a
brain needed back prop it would have
implemented back prop somehow right well
that's my opinion I think that this
locality has something I'll say in it
that makes the representation in the
brain more powerful or or and more
useful but my talk is not going to be
enough to convince you of that I think
right so this is just I mean this
audience doesn't need really a reminder
but this is just to explain why it's a
problem to learn synapse is based only
on pre and post synaptic activity the
problem is if you try to map a
particular input C to a particular
output particular output and you measure
an error and you want to know how to
change your magenta synapse here as a
function of that error the problem is
that if the error is positive for
example say okay maybe I should increase
the weight of my synapse and increase
the output but in the middle there's a
before the before that information
actually reached the output there's many
other sinuses and so in fact you have no
idea whether changing increasing or
decreasing that synaptic weight would
increase or decrease your error so you
cannot based learning
entirely on the output error and the
pre-synaptic activity so here instead of
this so here instead of here we're going
to backtrack a little bit
and what we're going to do is use a pure
top-down approach so we're going to
consider a spiky Network and we are
going to ask the spiky Network to learn
a task in spikes occur in time so I'm
going to think about how a spiky Network
could learn a dynamical system so here
we have a dynamical system available
here that could be behaviorally relevant
such as the position of the arm for
example and obeys an unknown dynamics f
of X and there is eventually some inputs
some sorry inputs or there could be some
motor commands sent to the arm
it's a dragster right so you have what
you have is actually the input you know
the input and you observe a trajectory
from that dynamical system it's not
polyup shows you your sensory feedback
from your arm moving in space and from
there you need to infer what's this
dynamic yes since but let's say we don't
only want to train that network to do
this dynamic we want that network to do
it as efficiently as possible right the
efficient so we sort of extend the
notion of efficient coding to the node
to efficient computing so we basically
want to minimize an objective function L
which would be a combination of an error
the error the network makes when
producing a trajectory that is supposed
to be produced by this dynamic f of X so
the estimation error made by the network
basically plus a cost which corresponds
to the total cost of neural activity we
don't want to spend too many spikes
Ottoman in neurons doing that task and
the last the last assumption with me to
make is how is this hidden variable this
state X going to represent they are
represented by the network ok and here
we assume the very simple decoder the
reason we did that is because we believe
that's essentially what the synapse can
do kind of sign ups cannot do much more
than that
so the decode the the variable X
hat is decoded by summing the spike
trains from that Network okay and
because we want to compute analog
variables then we transfer we transform
the spike trains s into a continuous
response or simply by filtering the
spike train for some time constant right
so if I like backtrack we take our spike
train we feel to them could see that as
a sort of synaptic integration then we
weighed them we some time with some
decoding weights D and then we recover
how state estimated X hat right so all
right our network gets an input it
produces an output that output is sum of
spikes filtered by train and there is an
underlying dynamical system that we do
not know but we're going to learn and
the idea is to as a network to produce
an output in below that is as close as
possible to the desired dynamics given
the input it receives that's a general
objective right so the opera's on the
decoding waits the to assume the network
has and we're going to keep them fixed
right the F we'll see how we can adjust
the half that the abs of the
feed-forward wait that's any input
commands into into the network clear
that's the problem at rates all right so
let's start with the simplest possible
of dynamics that we could try to learn
which is an elite integrator right so
our dynamics is X dot equal minus X plus
C and I neglected the time constant here
to clarification okay so we can we can
play around with this equation and also
write x dot plus X equal C obviously
that's equivalent right so we put C into
our network and then we read out X hat
from our network through this way to D
are now the rates are also the filter
spike trains right so you can also write
X hat dot plus X hat equals es which is
equivalent to X hat equal D R so here we
thought we want to match essentially two
spikes
that the left hand side on the right
hand side match as closely as possible
and natural way to do that is to use a
trick where we use the output of the
network GS which is also X hat dot plus
X hat and we directly subtract it from
the input C so that the effective input
to the network is not C but C minus X
hat dot plus X hat which is essentially
the estimate of C okay so if we do that
then we can remove essentially remove
the connections between the neurons we
don't need connections anymore right nor
just received their own coding errors
input okay and of course the ask the
network to keep that coding error as
small as possible so question is that is
that hard right and turns out that
really it isn't at least if we use a
spiky network so this is exactly the
same network here and I change a bit the
static sorry but here we have this input
which is a C minus
other with some of spikes that decoded
other basically the decoded output of
the network and we we are more the
network to minimize an error which is X
minus X hat in other word this input is
e dot plus e okay now we these networks
with these neurons are integrating fire
so they are going to integrate e dot
plus e such that the membrane potential
of one neuron will be the projection so
each here we place ourselves in into
space right we on a two dimensional
space which meant which means that there
is two inputs c1 and c2 and the state
variable X is two dimensional so here in
input space in X 1 X 2 space the
membrane potential of a neuron is the
projection of its input current
integrated so on the on the decoded
weights
so when so as soon as exactly the
feedforward weights I'm sorry so as soon
as this membrane potential crosses the
Fang fresh hole which is represented by
this dashed line here a spike will be
fired right and if a spike is fired it
will go through the loop and immediately
suppress II so what will actually happen
is that sorry here as soon as is trying
to cross the threshold it's immediately
brought back away from the threshold so
here I jumped ahead and decided that I
would use the same feed-forward and
decoding connections which turned out to
be the optimal if your network is large
okay so the is not able to cross that
barrier formed by the narrow facials
whatever it tries there will always be a
spike and it will be brought back to its
zero so if we have many neurons in our
population and they have different
decoding weights and these decoding
weights cover the entire input space
then this air will never be able to get
out of that bondage space right so here
we have just uncommitted integrated fire
neuron but thanks to their inhibitory
feedback they actually able to keep
their input the effective input that
which is the coding error in a very
small portion of space that is delimited
by the threshold the firing threshold of
all its its neurons is that clear how
does this network represent the variable
X then well it essentially provides a
very tight discrete approximation of
this integrated input X so this is a
true X here which is integrate the licky
integration of the input signal see
right and essentially if we start from
zero and this threshold is crossed a
spike is fired which is at which adds
the corresponding decoding rates to the
estimate right and then afresh then the
arrow goes back to zero
threshold is crossed again a new spike
is an indie coding way decided and so on
and so forth right so the difference
between the estimate X hat and the true
variable X is bounded by this little
this little zone here right and as a
result X hat has to track X it's
basically has no choice okay so the
question is how small is this error
right I mean we are used to see this
random spike trains and we're just
random looking spike trains and assume
that neurons are pretty reliable but in
fact here the motor on you have let's
say you have a you're willing to fire n
spikes you know that represent the
variable right then you can actually set
up the threshold at 1 / n spikes the
total number of spikes that you're
willing to fire right and the error will
never cross that threshold so will never
be larger than 1 divided by the number
of spikes in your in your network so
it's like the discretization limit you
cannot be more precise in representing
continuous signal with discrete events
like spikes if your neurons were really
noisy then it was at best its carrying 1
divided by the square root from the
number of spikes at best X is extracted
from the input C so it's like the key
integrated input C which comes from
outside X hat is extracted from the
spikes
well it's an it's a what you mean by
averaging over time it's it's an
estimate this continuous value of the
rate which is estimated from the
discrete space yes so the time scale
here which is actually the moment
potential time scale is a limit on the
precision at which you can represent
changes in your it's it's the temporal
precision basses give your
representation
so that's a very stupid computation it's
just the integration right but already
with a simple architecture so I forgot
to say of course we think of this a
negative look not necessarily as
something that is implemented in the
brain right but as something that is
implemented in the know population the G
matrix is random let's say right and if
there is enough it will always work yeah
so the threshold is actually setting the
cost so when I so this network is
essentially solving this from this
problem that I described before right
and this cost term here determine how
high you should set the threshold so
that's the price you're willing to pay
to pay to get an accurate representation
so the last thing we do is that instead
of putting an external loop here we
replace that by recurrent connections in
the network if you put pass through D
minus and then pass through F again
externally it's exactly the same thing
from neuron to neuron than to do with
direct connections equal to minus FD so
this time instead of having the network
as a wall predicting its input out we
have a record connection within the
network trying to cancel if you throw an
input received by each neuron its in
fact equivalent but we need a specific
structure in our system in general F
should be equal to the transpose but if
you have correlations and your input
might not be the case which is why I
keep F as a notation for the future
awaits so the question is how are you
going to learn these connections within
the circuits and it turns out to be
quite easy so we basically want to
start with an recurrent network that has
some random connections recurrent
connection matrix Omega let's see right
eventually converge to network that has
this perfect record matrix - FD which
would be the most the most efficient
network in representing a little
integration of its input and for this we
notice one thing that initially before
learning the membrane potential of each
neuron is a projection of X on its feet
or weights - the projection of the
neural activity on its recurrent
connections obviously by construction
right but at the end of learning if if
learning works then the moment potential
becomes the projection of the error X
minus X hat on the feed-forward waits F
and that's the very goal of the system
to minimize X - X hat so in turn in so
in fact the problem of coding efficiency
transform into a problem of keeping the
membrane potential as small as possible
and they are actually two equivalent
problems if we train the connections
here to keep the deviation in membrane
potential from zero as small as possible
we also train the network to represent
its input as efficiently as possible
it's the same problem so any learning
that would essentially be based on
minimizing the deviation in my mind
potential would do the job so we propose
the one which is based on a great
minimization of of the variance of the
voltage right and it's a very simple
rule so here we have a membrane
potential of the postsynaptic neuron
here we have time right and here we have
the membrane potential and suddenly we
get so this is neuron I let's say and
suddenly we get a spike from neuron K
okay so this spike here let's say the
spiciest bring us to the inventory
connection and so it will bring us here
that's not good right because now
instead of bringing my memories
potential back to zero I brought it a
bit below zero right so in that case I'm
going to decrease my inhibition in this
case on the other hand this emission was
not sufficient so in that
guess I want to increase my inhibition
essentially I want to stop learning when
the moment potential is brought at zero
okay so this actually we can never
forget this this is actually a learning
well that is - skv the I so it's based
on the under the correlation between the
presynaptic input and the postsynaptic
voltage will be minus sign it's an
option hebbian all right so this is just
to give you a more like global picture
what's going on here I mean we've made
several since I'm interesting in
biological circuit we of course pushed
it a little bit further in terms of
biological reality so here here we build
an AI network that is learning what that
I equivalent to the non there's no
network I was presenting before it's
basically a more realistic circuit but
otherwise the same principle and so
before learning if we randomly connect
this excitatory neurons or any between
neurons then they will fire all over the
place but it would be impossible to
recover the input from the respect
trains because there are sort of the
uterine complex firing patterns at the
end of learning the firing rate has gone
low much lower right so we actually
decrease the number of spectacle II and
yet we have improved drastically the
capacity of a decoder to recover
information from the input okay so this
representation is actually become much
better than it was initially so we had
this paradox of paradoxical effect that
the error the coding air of the network
goes down to very small levels despite
the fact that the the statistics becomes
more and more random okay so if you look
at single neurons they look noisier and
noisier if you look at the population
it's more and more precise so this is
this conundrum but I think could explain
this apparent difference between the
observation of neural activity that is
so noisy and the observation of micro
circuits that are so tightly organized
and less
yes just to get the big picture set up
right so you assume so X is a variable
that somehow in the input could be more
complicated to make that variable and
completely here well I mean in this in
this situation we don't predict anything
we just reproduce so this is
unsupervised in the sense that it
depends only on pre and postsynaptic
activity inside the network but later
when I'm going to Train it to a
dynamical system it will become
supervised because of course I have to
give it a training so you know to tell
the network do this right yes because
it's one competition exactly it turns
out this representation strategy will be
used all the time right so that's why
you spent some time explaining it but
this for the moment is not very
interesting it's just representation so
since this I did not so interesting I'm
going to switch to more interesting
stuff so first of all there's just
something that is non-trivial that is
done by this network I'm sorry for this
it turns out that initially we were we
were also using a learning rule that
that trained the feed-forward
connections right so that the food foil
connection would pick up structure in
the input and they are important to give
you this nice representation that are
sort of adapts it's the distribution of
input and so forth but it turns out that
even without this manual if you have
enough neurons the recurrent net
connections on their own will do this
that is they will extract not only
represent their input but extract the
structure of the end to do something
like independent component analysis and
reconstruct and allow you to reconstruct
these inputs more accurately so for
example here we train the network of
some auditory signals so spectrogram of
an auditory of speech initially in a
randomly connected Network
you cannot recover the information not
not really network of that size it's 60
neurons right but after learning it
becomes perfect at representing this
auditory signal and here it learned the
very non-trivial test statistics of
speech right if for example we would
test a system on a non speech signal it
would be very bad
so it became specialized to speak and
paradoxically the respect range look now
completely random if you were to look at
the receptive field aspect or temporal
receptive ear of those neurons it would
look like a single bandpass filter I'm
not very interesting either but in fact
there is a very elaborate conversation
occurring through the recurrent
connections which predict away which
predict away they're in customers and a
signature of this efficiency is it
almost perfect excited to really be to
rebalance about now existing in itself
[Music]
what do you mean the same
oh sorry these are different neurons
these are different neurons at the same
time so in fact if this nurten these
networks can be completely deterministic
we can make them completely
deterministic that's correct so this
this network for example each we can
show it's truly chaotic that is it has
lots of inputs and it has high
dimensional in fact and there's not a
single neuron that looks like another
neuron and as a result if we were to on
this trial if you didn't put any noise
or nothing right and repeated over to
hear the same space but if we shift it
once by here we change the timing all
the later spikes
it's extremely sensitive to any any
small perturbations and to explain that
is figure here so it's actually not a
chaotic Network right but it's a network
that is composed of neurons that have
all the same decoding weights so in
general this representation is highly
degenerate you have many neurons
representing similar feature
in the stimulus and so that means that
when they want to represent a single X
the population can do the same exact
thing with completely different ordering
of the spikes okay it is degenerate so
here I added a bit of noise to break the
symmetry between neurons and get this
switches from patterns little different
or not completely random ordering of
spikes by the network but you don't have
to if you have a larger networks I have
some reason to yeah it's a bit more
difficult to analyze that so I don't
know exactly why but I think that's
because there's no more neurons that are
exactly the same weight and and so you
get very complex trajectory in in these
little balls which end up being chaotic
it's bounded and it's not a otic alright
okay so now we're switching to the more
interesting problem which is we're going
to show that I mean this trick of
consoling integral fire on networks
considering that input will turn out to
be extremely useful when it comes to
learning and here we are focusing on
learning dynamical system so we want
this time to learn an unknown dynamics F
so the output of the network is not the
input anymore what you're extracting
from the network is a state state
variable and to how this data i/o
behaved properly of course we need to
have more recurrent connections in the
network in order to predict how the
state moves over time right so we start
with this sort or this leak integrator
and then a very very simple thing we
could do is we could restrict ourselves
to linear dynamical system so if you
have a if your dynamics is linear so you
have X dot equal ax plus C which this
covers a very wide range of dynamics
that are important for us like sensory
motor dynamics for example then there
it's it's quite easy to obtain these
dynamics because what you can do is you
can use the fact that X is represented
in the in the response of the neurons
right
you can decode X from gr okay
so if you get if you decode X from the R
then you can apply directly if you were
to knew the matrix a all you would have
to do is apply a plus identity here
which compensates for lilyc and then you
put that back into the input okay so
here I completely unfolded the network
including the inventory for the fast
inhibitory connections so that you could
see the two things working together so
if you do that yes sometimes simplify
here and the effective input to your
network becomes Z plus ax hat minus X
hat dot right and since this is a
virtually zero because of the inhibitory
loop you have X hat dot equal ax hat
plus C which is exactly two dynamics you
wanted to implement okay so here the
network acts as a pretty good auto
encoder it predicts it's only it
predicts the dynamics of its State and
consoles that prediction to get the
spike trains that would represent the
dynamic of that state which is a bit
weird but that works quite well okay we
actually the same procedure and same
accuracy then and in the integrator case
and finally to generalize to general
basis function to general function we
need nonlinearities in the network so
the idea is that you can approximate the
arbitrary function f of X as a sum of
basis functions and what we are going to
do is we're going to use nonlinear
functions of the rates and I'm not going
to be too precise about what we do
because it turns out it doesn't really
matter it could be done in about writes
none in your sign up says nonlinear
spiked generation at the end we just
need this to be nonlinear and you mean
you may ask why I mean it seems like so
it shouldn't matter right but what
happened is that these networks are
solving solving this problem why they
find the rates that minimize the
reconstruction error plus a cost so in
effect the rates are solving of the rate
of functions of X
because there's only one combination of
rates which which minimize that function
so ever need very generate the
representation is very constrained so if
you look inside the network you find
that the rates live on these low
dimensional manifolds that are
parameterized by the state they
represent so if you take any function of
some combination of the rates they will
end up being function of X plus some
situations that you can treat as noise
okay so that allow us to come to build
inside the network very rich set of
basis function of X the previous problem
was in solvable right you had lots of
rates you have lots of rates you had
lots of weights right and so you have
that many you had as many so equation to
solve as I about what's impossible but
now thanks to this squeezing of the
dimensionality by the efficiency
principle of the network you can solve
that problem easily because you have
lots of knots of basis function for a
very low dimensional space actually we
are currently using that unsupervised
learning
so we're basically the dynamics you let
will try to learn is the dynamics of
your inputs and it's it becomes very
indeed we discuss with Romans about that
it becomes similar in philosophy
all right so so now we are we know we
can approximate our function we know
there exists a set of weights that can
do it the draw but of course we need to
learn them so first of all of course
we're still spinning terms of a
recurrent Network so this unfolded
version is for clarity purposes what we
really have is a network of electron
connections some of them are doing this
predictive coding and learn by hunting
hebbian rule right and the other dates
are doing this sorry this cancellation
of the input and the others which turns
out to be the important one here are the
one that learnt two dynamics and that
the only difference between these two
connections is that they leave at a
different time scale okay the the
consoling connection the connection that
cancel the Internet's in blue are super
fast right because it did they basically
use spikes to reset the membrane
potential of the neurons whereas the
predictive connections use the response
the filtered spike train so they are
filtered before they are put into the
input and that's the only difference
that you need in fact you could
generalize this to any network as long
as you have two types games available
when to do the constellation and want to
do the prediction okay so now how do we
are we going to learn these synapses and
I have no idea how much time I have
three minutes all right so here for
people interested and I don't know why
it's so slow
to go through my slide but it's not
moving
all right port okay so what we are going
to do is we're going to use adaptive
control theory because it turns out that
this field is an engineering of yields
I've solved many of the issues that we
have with local learning and recurrent
networks all right so the idea is the
following
ah finally stop oh my god I don't know
why wait like that like this could be
better
so here the ideas if you want to if
you're let's say you have a student
network like we do right the student
network has a set of business functions
and some weights and you want to train
the weights such that the student is
going to behave like a teacher the
teacher is an unknown dynamical system
but products products but produce an
example trajectory X adaptive control
does is that it's abstract the output of
the students from the in from the output
of the teacher and then it feedback this
input inside the students so that feels
like a very stupid tragedy yeah once
leaving the students yes of course is
going to do to do what you want right
but it turns out that then you can use a
running rule which is w dot equal Phi of
X hat e transpose e being the air it's
local because it's only depend on the
correlation between the basis function
and the error and then you can show that
there's a yep enough function and it's
not often that learning has a Lyapunov
function which is defined as the error
plus the error of the tracking plus the
error of the estimation of the dynamical
system itself and this is the preneur
function is there it is negative blah
blah blah and it's guaranteed to
converge to the true parameter and to an
air of zero and believe me there's not a
lot of running rules in biology that do
that okay so that means is going to
converge quickly and accurately and it
can be directly translated into the
network by filling it its own error so
basically we assume that these neurons
here are receiving a feedback from the
error that they've made and this
feedback is injected in each neuron and
the learning will becomes then just a
function of the presynaptic activity
times the postsynaptic error feedback
which is local it is not a heavy on it
is not pre synaptic activity times post
synaptic activity it's pretty optic
activity times the postsynaptic in
feedback that time the postsynaptic
feedback for posting optic into it
received by the neural so it's something
that should occur sub in for example
locally within a neuron for example in
the
and rights so what's going to happen is
that in this micro secret when they turn
into more biologically plausible secrets
you will have initially silent
connections right and then the silent
connections would discover that they are
correlated with a feedback received from
a higher level yes which is a prediction
error for example if there's a
correlation this weight will increase
and it is not visible here because it's
just local but in fact at the global
level of the network this will actually
cancel the error so this will stop when
the errors consult and the network has
become autonomous and I believe this
principle could actually be generalized
to hierarchical network and many other
forms of learning in biology the
feedback is not only there to be back
propagated and to mediate learning it's
all there to push the secret in the
right direction and the to to gate and
and if you do that you can actually make
your system converge to the right
solution alright so just a few example
here we have a we have learned a little
guy that walks so basically we fed back
the input where is this these dots on on
the guy right and we ask the network to
reproduce that walking trajectory and
here to show how deeply the network has
a long trajectory we inactivated 70% of
the neurons so you may think that if you
inactivate 70% of the neurons the
network will crash but no it keeps on
walking and it just has a slight slowing
down right that's because of the huge
level of redundancies that this network
as well not exactly that redundancy
degeneracy it represents the trajectory
in many many different ways and I think
that's why it's actually able to
generalize to all trajectories and then
another example this is this is this is
only for the efficient a dose of of
attractor networks in the brain if it's
yeah so here we train the network to to
learn
a ring attractor so it's a two
dimensional input and it converge to a
ring and what happened then in neural
space is that the network reads these
bumps that looks a bit like the head
Direction cells in around us these bumps
can point and it can be in any position
on on the network good thing of them are
representing the orientation the
direction of the inputs on the on the
circle and they are these are a
synchronous irregular spike trains even
if this is a very deterministic Network
and we can play the same game and and we
can inactivate the bump so it's a line
it's an attractor network relying on
self-excitation right so in theory if
you were to inactivate part of the cells
things which should crash completely you
should start moving or but it doesn't so
what happen is you know the green line
there was actually biased but what
happened is that when you inactivate
part of the neurons the other take over
temporarily and then you stop in
activating and the network comes back to
its initial the bump comes back to its
initial position right so we we have
made a system that not only has
attractors but becomes extremely robust
through a most massive a perturbation
that was explaining White's robust and I
will go to the conclusion I'm every
sorry all right
so conclusions I don't like conclusions
shortcomings right we need dance and
highly organized connections so the
question is how would this network
scales if we go from the Rays of
microcircuit scales to the more brain
and that's an open question it's not as
obvious that we go we would go less and
less precise as we increase the scale
then we need to do hierarchies and
observables and hierarchical learning
and so on and so forth I always have
problems with people I don't like single
spikes for some reason but the brain
computes with space I insist and I would
like to apply that to shallow
hierarchical networks like the brain is
so I think that actually this feedback
it's completely crazy idea for the
moment but it's the
strategy of using the feedback to
control the network could a lowers to
you I would solve the same problem then
dig networks but with a single spike
rather than a specific multi spike
combination asan for spy combinations
across multiple neurons is e is e the
primitives that we need to deal with so
in this system can do do subsequent
spikes mean something different compared
to us because you might have phenomena
like this occurring in the network right
you may have phenomena like triplets or
things like that occurring because of
the dynamic in the network but we have
assumed that the decoder is not able to
extract this information the decoder is
a postsynaptic integration of of spike
trains and that's true it's a limit so
when I said the brain computes respect
maybe I should clarify this in the brain
contracts computer memory potentials
with its biophysics inside the cells and
the spikes are keeping this computation
coordinated between neurons unbounded
it's still very a very sort of read like
view of spiking as things by counts
network with friends will produce Axl
compute X but it crucial to know all
variables of going to X or if my ex is a
dynamical system is 25 Barrios arrived
but only one is computed into the
network a would that approach be able to
reconstruct all 25 eventually are you
saying what happened if you were trying
to read out only one variable in these
25 variables from the network exactly
what I'm asking but the idea is that if
I'm trying to make a computation but I
have an input only a low dimensional
subset of all for some kind of the
tycoon's like structure allowing me to
still do the performance and I'm not
quite sure I can I can see how that will
work in this so you're totally right up
in you nailed it so here there is no
hidden variable we need to observe the
full trajectories well we need to
observe the state right if we we're to
observe only we add a projection of the
state only like a one dimensional
predation of about 25 dimensional state
the brain the network would not be able
to learn so you might want to have a bit
like force learning or particle filters
you may have to want to have like
underlying complex dynamics in the
network right and use them as a sort of
bank to predict your inputs I think
probably a combination between the two
and you thought about how you would
build something like an oscillatory
framework on top of this
we played around with it I mean you can
be again as many oscillators in other
these are dynamical systems now we do
have oscillation the network as soon as
there's delays and we do have phase
coherence and all things like that but
there are they are phenomena they are
not cooling they are not good in
quantities their phenomena now I'm not
saying that is the only thing that there
is right there is problems of
interferences between stimuli when you
come to you through the making decisions
or stuff like that but when it comes to
the complexity of where the network can
do in fact these networks are very very
high capacity right they can implement
dynamical system of dimension and
divided by T where where n is the number
of neurons in the network and in fact if
you train one dynamical system and train
another you won't erase the first one
because the network has so many
dimension and this network no activity
leave on this low dimension you don't
care about the other dynamics
they act like noise for you and you can
learn anyone so the capacity is still
very high but it is not capturing any
thing useful about currents and
solutions
so we are mom the reminds me of some
recent work by you know like what would
be like different yes
so the follow network is a network that
is not it's it's a if you want it it is
using adaptive control but it is reusing
that in a rate model and they
implemented in a spike network by
approximate integrated fire neuron as a
continuous transfer function applied to
to the input right so in for when it
comes to learning this is similar
principle for coding efficiency is we
are not seeing the same scale their
network a there are 30,000 neurons
firing at 30 Hertz and we can do the
same thing we've got a neurons firing at
their notes you have the membrane
voltage crossing a threshold but I think
that the first-order hodgkin-huxley is
more like the derivative crossing a
threshold do you think that would work
for your system too well we are we are
extending that framework so for the more
in the inventory loop as only one time
scale so it's it's not able to capture
dynamics in the input for example so now
we are using vertical time scale and the
idea is that if you have multiple
inhibitory timescales in your system and
you train the network to counsel not
only V but the derivative of V integral
derivative of V etc then it will be able
to be a bit more efficient in terms of
spiking because if you approximate the
dynamics of the system in its decoding
now it does not mean then the neurons
would respond to their receive in ermine
potential
[Applause]